those swords are made really
well because they're like layered bits
of bamboo together i think it would have
to be a really like perfect storm for
that to actually happen seeing as how
like these aren't very sharp hi my name
is tecla hudirova i'm a stunt woman and
martial arts world champion and i've
been doing nunchucks and martial arts in
general for about 18 years today we'll
be looking at nunchuck scenes and movies
and judging how real they are
it's very traditional nunchuck style
it's a lot of the passing under the hand
stuff which is super cool and like more
old school the longer chain ones might
be more practical the longer the chain
the further your reach is this is about
the length i think that they were in
that last clip because the ones i
compete with it's a shorter chain so you
can do more like flourishy things with
it
not only did he hold it normal grip
which is your thumb facing the chain
pretty much but whenever he switched his
his hands he had them backwards uh a a
few times you don't see that often it's
a style i think it's like knife you know
you have like your regular standard grip
and then you have like ice pick where
it's upside down so i guess that'd be
like the ice pick version which is cool
this is the normal grip but it's neat to
see it this way because obviously it
works the same way but
it's just cool
you don't have to start under the armpit
i think that's another just
traditional move they usually like spin
it catch it under the armpit and then
shoot it back out again i think maybe
that's more of a sneaky
way to do it as opposed to like being
loaded here right you're here and then
everyone's like oh there's no way
like traditional weapons especially come
from like farm tools this was just for
like smacking grain out of hay and like
wheat and stuff and then someone's like
hmm this works on grain i wonder what
it'll do to someone's face i can't rape
bruce lee ten
all right maybe maybe nine because he
showed off for way too long
you can kind of see
a little bit and some of it where maybe
the actress isn't completely that
well-versed with the nunchucks they're a
little bit slower she's kind of using
more of her body and like more of her
arms and stuff instead of just like
moving the nunchuck very skillfully but
obviously she's quite skilled there's a
few cool moves though the neck
sliding under the legs and hitting him
it's pretty cool but it's definitely not
as realistic to think that she wouldn't
just be grabbed or something and she's
being a lot more like calculating and
like choreographed with it
the last move where she like puts it on
her foot and kicks it i've seen actually
like don in forms so i'd say like seven
but i still love it
oh double
there we go
he's just doing the same combo over and
over
i love it it's funny how
often it's just like the demonstration
of the weapon especially with nunchucks
is like
the bit that that is so highlighted he
did a good job like obviously was him
doing it and like the move where he like
crosses them isn't very easy to do
if i were to be in a fight with
nunchucks i think i would just try to
make the big swinging strikes the best
one's probably from top to bottom at the
angles you do side to side or like a
nice uppercut anything else ends up
being a lot more specific also i mean
groin knees those are always
like defaults for
self-defense moves and a nunchuck to the
kneecap wouldn't be very comfortable so
that'd probably be a good one too so
like what he did you know just like
wailing on him was probably
like a really
you know good default
i want to say they're foam ones in that
scene too just by the weight that it
looked like they had when it bounced
back real nunchucks are made out of wood
they're illegal in california it's just
always such an interesting question that
like people ask that kind of confuses me
sometimes about like are they real if
you're training with a sword if it's
made out of metal it is but if it's not
sharp then i guess it's not real like
these are real they're just foam so it's
like a weird
you know like what the definition of a
real weapon is he just did the
demonstration which was really cool but
the actual fight bit was like three
moves and the nunchuck bounced back so
like a five
yes concealed carry nunchucks
so cool i've been known to just keep
them in a backpack or a purse because i
forgot that they're there so they are
very like concealable
that's dope
i love that he used it
to
take on a bunch of people surrounding
him because i feel like that's probably
the best use of it just because if you
spin around fast enough like people
aren't going to want to attack you i
think that is a really good use of a
flailing weapon like if you had a stick
someone might grab it and like disarm
him or you know like it's it's an easier
thing to
catch when it's like one stick but when
it's unchecked like it's terrifying it's
scary for the person wielding it much
less someone in front
those swords are made really
well because they're like layered bits
of bamboo together i think it would have
to be a really like perfect storm for
that to actually happen
seeing as how like these aren't very
sharp but it's donnie yen so you know
like
it's possible
if they wanted to swarm him they could
have like beaten him but i think it's a
really
good way to capture the like efficiency
and the use of the actual weapon so i
don't know nine a fellow checker eh
[Music]
yeah i mean rolling it over your hand is
always harder convolves letting go of
one of them and just letting it roll
over your hand and get to the other one
it's hard to do with the longer chain
because you have to be able to get that
so i'd say like straight strikes are the
easiest and then something with a spin
and then something with a release as far
as difficulty tears so like that
difficulty scale
and the speed i think are pretty good
signs of like
expertise
you gotta love ninja turtles it's like
the dueling pianos thing keep practicing
[Music]
see this is where nunchucks get a bad
rep they're like oh no one's actually
doing anything with them and then the
guy with the stick comes in and beats
everyone up but
if they actually got close enough where
chuck would hit someone
maybe the guy with the bo staff wouldn't
have to be there they showed some good
expertise with the nunchucks but there
was zero fight
actual interaction so i'll have to give
it like a two or three
but again for the demonstration bit
maybe like a six or seven
all right oh pass around the back nice
again with this you see a lot of just
straight strikes not so much fancy stuff
when you're actually interacting with
people with which again like it's the
diagonal strikes the sideways ones
upwards hitting the guy out of the air
was probably the least practical thing i
still liked don yen's version
better with like everyone attacking at
once because again this was a little
more choreographed where like all the
bad guys come in at their designated
time which is plausible you know of
course but i think if you're a mob
trying to end up hurting someone you
just like go like one two three let's go
finishes them off with a kick he used a
lot more
you know like martial arts kicks and
other other movement as opposed to just
swinging the nunchuck around because
obviously someone who can do nunchucks
should have some background in martial
arts it made it feel more realistic
because of that as well the strikes were
awesome but then there were a few of the
more intricate things like it when he
like wrapped the guy's arm which i feel
like
took a little longer than it probably
practically would like if someone's
punching you don't really have all that
time for that to happen it's plausible
of course like while it still felt
very
specifically choreographed it was a lot
more believable than the kick-ass one
where there were just like so many
specialty moves
would really suck to get cracked like
across the jaw or like the eyes
obviously a sharp weapon is more
practical in a real fight if you're
actually wanting to like hurt people
that bad but i do think you know what
you're doing they end up being like a
stick i used to think that they're not
as effective or as good because i
thought they'd like bounce back but
again if you don't hit with anything but
the last bit it just whips by a little
bit and then you have a lot of power in
that last bit maybe not the easiest
thing to use in a real fight but i do
think they could probably be pretty
devastating if you know how to use them
right maybe like a seven
that would suck i feel like the physics
of that doesn't quite work but it's a
cool move you know
i liked the bruce lee character dodging
he's very skilled to dodge that close to
the nunchucks but i liked him going
stepping offline and like punching the
guy and taking the nunchucks which is
what you want to do with disarming a
weapon of any sort right like you want
to kind of get in past it and get past
the like that end where that's the most
power is
there was one bit where he like hits the
pipe and then hits the guy's hand which
is really like a cool
take on it because like hitting fingers
would suck
whereas you're not gonna disarm the pipe
out of someone's hand important muscles
for using nunchucks uh one of the main
ones is actually wrists for the more
intricate movements and then obviously
your arm and your back and
power
comes from your hips range of motion is
very important arguably more important
than muscle mass this one's tough
because i liked this one it showed like
a variety of styles but like if we have
to rate it on practicality like seven or
something
these people need to start holding on to
their weapons a little better yeah it's
funny to
keep seeing that theme of just people
taking nunchucks from other people in
all of these i've never noticed that
until you have them back to back you're
like what's going on
i don't know if i would block an axe
with it just because i'm not sure how
sharp the axe is and how heavy and like
it's kind of a small chain so it
it's not unlikely that it might snap it
there's also other blocks like this ends
up actually being a block as well
because you're here you're blocking all
that and then you can also kind of block
if you just hold them
their stick on your arm so that's a good
block as well again like i don't think
they're the most secure things to block
with but that's not a horrible move
especially if you're stepping off to the
side just to like ensure you're
gonna not be hit if something does
happen probably perry instead of just
block straight on i don't think it
showed off like the practicality of
nunchucks all that well you'd have to be
very skilled and very specific with your
movement to be able to pull that off at
all and i wouldn't recommend it so maybe
like a five but it was a cool little
scene
there's that move again
i mean he obviously knows what he's
doing based on our criteria from earlier
like the intricacy switching hands and
the speed at which he's moving them and
the spins and everything so that's
really cool to see i
grip it
like a maybe a thumb width away from the
chain and the top because that's where
you have the most control over the other
stick as well i guess for like distance
and like just the straight strikes
you might grip it a little lower and
then also depending on the intricacy of
your movement sometimes for some moves
you want to grip it a little bit lower
so that you can get it around your hand
for that or you want to grip it a little
higher if you're doing like a finger
spin or something but generally speaking
you want to be close to the chain on top
and then all you have to worry about is
where the chain is flinging the rest of
it so it's a lot more controlled
i don't do the like eyes fluttering
thing it is kind of indicative of not
knowing
the distance and like location of the
nunchucks or any weapon really like i
think people do that with bo staff and
sword and stuff as well even if it's
just foam like if i throw it and lose
track of it then i do that
obviously but i do
know where they're going most of the
time but you definitely hit yourself
quite a bit especially at first when
you're still learning and if you're not
being smooth a lot of times it's like
funny bone which is fantastic back of
the head which i'm not even sure how
that gets there but that's a good one
also makes a really good sound they're
definitely special
but i've never like
knocked myself out with them or like
anything horrible so practicality-wise i
mean like probably like the four or five
again just because like
some of the strikes didn't look like
they hit exactly
oh this is the
quintessential scene i can't rag on this
cancelled immediately i like how
i feel like it is realistic how few
times they hit each other with them
and how much more it is kind of like a
distraction like that first move he did
he did like a briefly just like a
distraction move and then kicks him in
the uh like the ankle to throw him off
so like that stuff's more practical i
think it felt
maybe not like gritty realistic but it
did feel realistic within like if you're
sparring with someone you're gonna show
off your moves and everything and like
kind of like test the waters and the
distance which they were doing a lot
during like demonstration periods and
just kind of showing off very simple
straight across strikes which would work
but yeah i think that's one of the best
ones we've seen for sure i'd say that's
the 10.
so the spear kind of
beat the nunchucks in that i think even
though she won definitely
less intricate movement it was kind of
nice that there wasn't a demonstration
of skill in this one it was just like it
went right to the fight maybe the
nunchucks weren't the right choice for
that girl to use in that fight against
the spear it wasn't bad i just i think
the other ones obviously were much
stronger
showing
the benefit of nunchucks and like the
practicality of it and the impact of
them because even in this like she hit
the girl across the face but like there
wasn't a lot of
impact on how that would actually feel
and i think the distance again looked a
little off because they were so close so
a lot of her strikes ended up being a
little weaker looking the distance felt
a little off and the filming didn't
quite showcase the nunchucks as well as
some of the other clips would have so
maybe like a four or three can you
imagine i'm like i've been in a hundred
nunchuck fights
thanks so much for watching if you
enjoyed this click the link above